so far we've examined the basic
structure of Ajax requests alongside
some basic use cases we've used dev
tools to identify that Facebook and
Twitter use Ajax requests to load
content on the fly
we've seen how Reddit and the reddit
enhancement suite use Ajax requests to
load data inline as users request
information and we've briefly taken a
step back to examine how even big
websites like Yelp take advantage of
external api's to add functionality to
their websites in the next part of the
lesson you'll be diving into building
the moving planner app which is going to
integrate who a street view in the
background
the New York Times API to give us these
articles and the Wikipedia API to give
us these articles for this quiz I want
you to spend a moment to brainstorm what
kind of API you could use to mix and
match in interesting ways take a look
through the massive list of API is in
the instructor notes and take a moment
to think about some kind of cool novel
way you could integrate different API s
together in a single web app once you
finish your brainstorm type what API is
you want to try out in this box